[MUSIC]
I grew up in a family
with two amazing moms.
My mom Jane gave birth to my brother
Jonah, and my mom Deb gave birth to me.
This is a photo of all of
us at their wedding day,
after marriage equality was
passed in Massachusetts.
But even growing up in liberal Boston,
our family structure was still unusual.
To some, it was unnatural.
People even questioned whether
we were a real family.
They would say things like,
isn't it like weird that you and
your brother aren't biologically related?
No, he's my brother.
Do you wish you knew your dad?
No, I've never thought of my
parents sperm donor as my dad.
But like,
>> [LAUGH]
>> Do you think you might be gay because
your parents are gay?
Well, I don't know.
Those first two questions were easy,
because our family's love,
definitively, did not depend
on genetic connection.
But they were frustrating, and
constant reminders of how important
genetic connection was to other people.
But that last question
really got me thinking.
Because by the time I was 17 years old,
even though I had a boyfriend,
I had kind of started to develop
a crush on a girl in my school.
So I thought, am I?
And if so, why?
So I set out in search of an explanation.
I opened my computer, and
typed into Google two words, gay gene.
That Google search for an explanation for
my feelings launched a ten year
journey of learning about genetics.
I took genetics classes in college,
consulted for
genetics companies, and
I'm studying it again, here at Stanford.
And I want to share with
you what I've learned.
First and foremost,
this stuff is really complicated.
A big part of who we are is our DNA and
our environment.
Our DNA is the biological matter
that carries our genetic code.
And our environment is where we grew up,
who we surrounded ourselves with, and
what events happened in our lives.
It would be great if we
could hold DNA constant, and
adjust our environment to see which would
be more powerful, in which circumstance.
But unfortunately, it's not that simple.
We can ever truly disentangle our DNA
from our environment because they're
constantly interacting, and
changing each other, and they change us.
So it's futile to ask
which is more important,
because it is only through their
interaction, that they can change
things like our health, human behavior,
and who we are and become.
So I want to walk through three really
complex examples to explain how
this works.
And I'm going to break them down
into their most essential parts.
Let's start with an example
that affects our mental health,
by looking at a study on depression.
Scientists identified a genetic
profile linked to depression.
For simplicity, let's call it D gene.
Scientist looked at kids with D gene,
and without D gene,
to see why some develop depression and
others don't.
They found that kids with D gene,
who had negative experiences,
such as the loss of a family member or
a serious illness,
were two times as likely as kids
without D gene to develop depression.
But they also found that kids with D gene,
who had not had negative experiences,
were no more likely than kids without
D gene to develop depression.
The lack of an experiential factor
essentially equalized the chances that
kids would develop depression,
regardless of whether they had D gene.
And we also know that 50% of people with
depression have no genetic history for it.
Which means you can have D gene,
and never develop depression, or
you can live with depression, and
have no genetic connection to it.
So now that we've talked about
an example in human health,
let's talk about an example in human
behavior, specifically, friendly or
pro-social behavior versus
aggressive behavior.
Scientists thought that they'd
identified a gene linked to aggression.
Let's call it A gene.
They looked at people with
A gene to study the prevalence
of friendly versus aggressive behaviors.
And first, they looked at people with
A gene, who had had aversive life events,
such as neglect,
in the first two years of their lives.
They found a statistically significant
relationship between aversive life
events and exhibiting aggressive behavior.
But interestingly,
they also found that people with A gene,
who had had positive experiences,
actually exhibited more friendly
behavior than people without A gene.
So had scientists really
found the aggression gene, or
had they found the friendly gene?
A gene, itself, doesn't determine
whether we'll be friendly or aggressive.
Our environment plays a huge role as well.
When it comes to health and
behavior, scientists, presumably,
are looking to get to
the root of a problem,
to improve our individual and
societal well-being.
But I want to switch gears,
and talk about something that
shouldn't be viewed as a problem, but
is often studied in the same way.
So now let's get back to
what got this whole genetics
research party started, sexuality.
For decades, scientists have tried to find
the gay gene without much success.
They're having trouble testing
their hypothesis because first and
foremost, multiple genes are involved
in any complex human trait.
Scientists know that a minimum of 2, but
up to 16 genes could influence
our eye color alone.
So how could one determine sexuality?
And even when we know
the genes that are involved,
our environment plays a huge role as well.
But it's not just testing the hypothesis
that's a problem, it's defining it,
that's been challenging as well.
Because what are scientists
trying to identify
by finding a gay gene anyway, and why?
Is it who we're capable
of being attracted to,
who we're capable of loving,
or how we identify?
When it comes to sexuality,
there are so many variables involved,
and they're complex, fluid,
non-binary, and socially influenced.
So this complicates scientists ability
to even define terms like sexuality,
gender, love, attraction,
what's genetic, and what's not.
And yet somehow, when I was 17 years old,
I somehow expected those scientists and
their studies to define me.
So why did I do it,
why did I Google gay gene?
Why did I think it was so simple?
Why did I need an explanation for
my feelings?
Why did I need to know why?
And why does anyone need to know why?
I realize that I Googled gay gene to
begin with, because my whole life,
I've gotten question,
after question, after question,
that reinforced that our
genetics made a real family,
that only genetic
connection is legitimate,
that our genetics could
predestine who I become.
So we shouldn't use words like genetic or
biological or
natural as synonyms for normal,
because that's how I internalized them,
and it sent me on a 10 year journey
to study something that I ultimately
find really fascinating, but that
started as me seeking an explanation for
my feelings,
as if they were a problem to be solved.
Now I know that my family,
my sexuality, my identity,
they're not problems at all, and
they don't require an explanation.
No one should have to Google
anything to justify their existence,
because whoever you are, is okay,
whether it's found to be true for
you genetically from the beginning,
or becomes true for you.
If I've learned anything from all of this,
it's that our families,
our identities, our health, our behavior,
basically anything about us,
cannot be reduced to genetics alone.
Because humans are so
much more complicated than that.
So yes,
genetic discoveries have tremendous
potential to benefit humankind, but
genetics does not define our humanity.
Not my mom's, not my brother's,
not mine, and not yours.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]